it's monday the 24th of may
the international backlash takes off eu
leaders meet to discuss sanctions
against belarus after a ryanair flight
carrying an
opposition journalist was forced to land
travel rebels spain says it's open to
british visitors from today but will the
uk's amber warning
deter tourists an anti-racism campaigner
critically ill in hospital in london
after being shot in the head
covet canines the dogs trained to smell
kovid19
and help stop the spread of the virus
[Music]
irreplaceable thieves steal silver and
gold belonging to mary queen of scots
from a castle in sussex
and from midweek onwards we are going to
finally see some dry brighter and warmer
conditions but until then
there's still some wet weather to
contend with i'll have the details for
you later
a very good morning to you governments
around the world have
condemned belarus after jets from the
eastern european country forced
a ryanair plane carrying an opposition
blogger to land
officials in minsk say a mig fighter
escorted the boeing 737 to the ground
following
an alleged bomb scare well the leading
opposition journalist
roman processed was on board and was
arrested when the plane landed
the foreign secretary said there would
be serious implications
while the head of the eu commission
described it as a hijacking
our defense and security correspondent
aleister bunkel reports
this photo of roman protozovich was
taken in athens
just before he boarded the ryanair
flight for lithuania
he never got there as flight 4978 was
about to cross into lithuanian airspace
it was diverted to minsk because of a
bomb scare
the aircraft was escorted by fighter
jets personally ordered
by the belarussian president alexander
lukashenko
when we received information that there
was a civil aircraft in our airspace
with a possible bomb threat
the operational duty central command
post the air defense
was put on high alert this was done in
order to assess the situation
and subsequently make the right decision
once on the ground bella russian police
arrested the well-known opposition
journalist
no bomb was found on board we all were
being checked and the
they were standing in front of us with
guns and
they were just
well we didn't know what to do because
we we didn't
they were checking our suitcases but at
the same time they were arresting the
journalists roman protozovich runs
a prominent anti-government blog called
nexter
following mass protests against
belarus's president lukashenko last
year the belarusian government
designated nexter
an extremist organization and put
protezovic on the most wanted list
he fled to poland for his own safety
they're not offering a safe skies over
which our citizens can fly
and we must therefore immediately stop
overflight of belarus
and prevent all flights from entering or
leaving that country
we should also immediately ground
bellavia airlines
which is their flag carrier because it
is clearly not safe
for them to fly back to belarus the u.s
secretary of state anthony blinken said
it was a brazen and shocking act to
divert a commercial flight
and arrest a journalist and nato
secretary general
described it as a serious and dangerous
incident
which requires international
investigation
lukashenko's political rival herself
exiled in lithuania
said that she was in no doubt that the
belarusian president
was responsible
today lukashenko personally caused an
international scandal
used military aircraft against civilians
of belarus and european countries
to reprise just one person no one else
is safe
anyone could be in roman protozovich's
place
the ryanair flight has now finally
landed in lithuania
and a criminal investigation has been
opened this incident
will have big international implications
because
in effect the leader of a european
country
has forced a passenger jet out of the
sky
under false pretenses and for his own
political means
alastair uncle sky news
now british tourists are expected to
head to spain today
after the country said it would welcome
visitors who had a negative coronavirus
test but the country is still of course
on the uk's amber list
and the government here has asked people
not to travel
to spain well let's talk to our
correspondent emma birchley who's at
gatwick morning emma are we expecting
the flights to spain to be pretty full
today then
well i'm not sure about that the first
one to lanzarotti
heads off at eight o'clock i have to say
i haven't found anyone
who's going to be on that flight there
are more flights however at around
midday to barcelona malaga
and to ibiza so i shall stop many more
passengers over the next couple of hours
to see if any of them are heading there
the fact is spain's very keen to get
british
tourists british travelers back there 18
million people from the uk in a normal
year would head
to spain so you can understand why the
spanish prime minister would say is very
delighted
to welcome people back so it means they
won't have to have this pcr test when
they get there
the problem is is that uh spain remains
on the uk's
amber list so even if you get there
without needing a test you still need a
test before you head back to the uk
then you face ten days self-isolation at
home with tests on day two and eight
you can pay for an additional test on
day five it's called test to release
but what you're looking at still is
hundreds of pounds
of tests it is good news though for the
travel industry
and earlier i spoke to an easy jet pilot
who was heading in he'd been furloughed
until
uh yesterday today he was heading out to
edinburgh
a captain ian welsh and he spoke about
how pleased he was that things are
getting back to normal now that's great
news that spain won't require a pcr test
to travel it's a huge
business for us travel to spain and
we're delighted to see
that i think it's going to be slow it's
going to be a slow ramp up
but hopefully there'll be more countries
come onto the green list and
we think maybe things will pick up in
june and hopefully july and august will
be
pretty busy
[Applause]
now as it stands people shouldn't really
be heading to an ambulance country just
to go on holiday and the transport
secretary grant
urged people to use their common sense
but everyone will be watching to see
whether the lists change which countries
are on which list
are sometime at the beginning of june
hey emma thank you
well sort of come for you this morning
at half past seven
what can the rest of the world really do
after president lukashenko of belarus
forced that plane carrying an opposition
journalist
to land a quarter to eight will meet the
team who've trained a group of dogs to
detect whether someone has
kovid 19. and at 20 past eight we'll
speak to a unicef worker in the
democratic republic of congo as hundreds
of homes are destroyed
in a huge volcanic eruption
now a black equal rights campaigner is
critically ill in hospital after being
shot on the street in london 27 year old
sasha johnson suffered a gunshot wound
to the head in the early hours of
yesterday morning
jemima walker reports
this is sasha johnson a prominent
anti-racism campaigner she's fighting
for her life in hospital after
reportedly being shot in the head
the incident happened in southwark in
southeast london
police were called to an address on
consort road behind me
at just after three o'clock in the
morning on sunday
it is there they say they found a 27
year old woman who had suffered from a
gunshot wound
detectives from the metropolitan
police's specialist crime command are
leading the investigation
in a statement the met says while the
investigation is at an early stage
there is nothing to suggest the woman
who was shot was the subject of a
targeted attack
or that she had received any credible
threats against her prior to this
incident
last august sasha johnson organised
large-scale march
to protest against systemic racism
she told sky news what drives her
activism
the uk disassociates from racism but we
have to remember
the wind rush generation came here when
we're funding water bomb other countries
and people are coming here for safety
and rest then we're fleeing them away
from our xenophobia
so we're not disassociating from we're
saying yes is here we need to address it
now we're in 2020.
we've come too far for racism to still
be a problem
the 27 year old mother is a committee
member of the political party
taking the initiative the party says
it is with great sadness that we inform
you that our own sasha johnson
has sustained a gunshot wound to her
head
sasha has always been actively fighting
for black people
and the injustices that surround the
black community
so far there have been no arrests police
are appealing to anyone with any
information to come forward
jemima walker sky news
well let's have a look at some of the
other main stories for you this morning
and a set of rosary beads carried by
mary queen of scots to her executioner
amongst the items missing
after a raid at arundel castle west
sussex police say the gold and silver
items are irreplaceable
and were taken by force from a public
display cabinet
on friday night
at least 15 people are thought to have
died after a volcano erupted in the
democratic republic of congo
lava has been flowing from mount
neregongo into nearby villages
it's thought 500 homes have been
destroyed
at least 14 people have died after a
cable line snapped in northern italy
investigators say the cable line broke
near the top
and the cable car fell to the ground and
rolled down a hill a child was a lone
survivor
they were taken to hospital in a
critical condition italy only
reopened a few weeks ago allowing
allowing travel between regions
after a winter of covid 19 restrictions
former england manager roy hodgson has
been appointed to the panel carrying out
a review of
fans role in football the group chaired
by former sports minister tracy crouch
will meet for the first time
today
now the government's announced it will
provide extra support for people forced
to self-isolate in nine areas of england
the money will go to regions with higher
rates of coronavirus infections ali
fortescue
has got some more for us on this so it's
more money but not more money in
people's pockets to stay at home just
more money to move somewhere else yeah
that's right and i mean labour have long
been calling for more financial support
so i think that will be the criticism of
this today but we know that
self-isolation has long been a core part
of the government's
strategy and it has been concerned there
haven't been enough incentives to help
people to self-isolate
so what this pilot scheme will mean is
that nine areas including
yorkshire and humber cheshire some parts
of london
somerset will get extra support it will
be tailored for each area so for example
some areas
will get this buddying scheme which is
about helping people
struggling with their mental health if
they're having to isolate for prolonged
periods of time
perhaps the the most helpful there will
be accommodation that they say will be
provided to people living
in crowded households as i say though
the criticism
will be that this comes too late that it
doesn't come
go far enough in terms of financial
support matt hancock though saying that
this will be
a vital way of helping with new variants
and we know that there has been
a real problem with compliance when it
comes to self-isolation
okay ali thank you well let's have a
look at the latest coronavirus
data for you and there have been 2235
new cases in the most recent 24-hour
period
five more deaths have been reported
which means the total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test
is now 127 721.
meanwhile another 205 410 people have
had their first vaccination
556 951 have had their second
that's the highest number of second
vaccines in one day since the rollout
began
in total 60.59
million injections have now been given
across
the uk
now the woman who led the manhunt for
raul moat has described the moment she
learned he'd
shot and injured one of her own officers
sue sim was just weeks into the job as
acting chief constable
where northumbria police were faced with
a double shooting
and a fugitive on the run in our new
podcast series storycast 21 we look back
at the case that defined her career
in the full gaze of the world's media
hello there this is the gunman from
berkeley last night
my name is raul mode what's the
following is i'm not covering it alive
you just hosted me for so many years
police are as we speak in a
confrontation situation
with the suspect can i stress to the
public that
moat is still at large a man
fired a shotgun through the window of
this house that a young woman inside
a man was then shot and killed on the
grass outside
if there was any change that came to our
notice
that we would tell you the community
because it's important that we have
that level of trust with you
[Applause]
i don't know whether anybody who hasn't
been
in this position can understand what it
feels like to be told that an officer
under your care and perfection has been
gunned down
david rathband was sitting waiting and
hoping to
actually stop ralmate and
ralmot had gone up to him and had
callously
shot him in the head which resulted in
in
david being blinded this
was a manhunt happening in real time
nobody knew what was going to happen
next
at 41 in the morning i got a phone call
which was the worst phone call
of my professional life and she said to
me
see he's shocked and we think he's
killed one of our own
this was about to turn into one of the
uk's
biggest ever manhunts it felt like
being within a conflict zone
what is a very beautiful very remote
very quiet small area you
had the world's media descended on it
they're doing
everything they can to try to find him
10 years later
i still get stopped by people it's
important that we
have that level of trust with you
they believe that i helped them get
through this terrible incident
police officers are just running down
now if i get out of the way
my biggest fear of course we're not
being able to bring
real note to justice
you can relive the drama of that manhunt
in this week's episode of storycast21
that's available now in the sky news app
and via
all podcast providers
and now let's bring you more on our top
story this morning britain and the
united states strongly criticizing the
president
of belarus after he ordered a flight a
rhino flight carrying an opposition
journalist to land
as it was flying over the country i mean
dispatching a mig
to make sure it went down let's talk to
the business minister
ann marie trevelyan good morning to you
look officially what is the government
reaction to this
uh good morning well as the foreign
secretary
uh said last night uh and i have no
doubt uh there will be statements this
week in the house this is
unacceptable and we are very uh
concerned by that behavior
and i think all parties uh have been
very clear that this is a
breach of uh normal
uh international laws and i have no
doubt the foreign sector will make
more uh clarity on his message from last
night
yes but he said there will be serious
implications what does that mean
so as i'm not the foreign secretary i'm
afraid i can't answer that
question for you i think it's very clear
that the international community has
uh in one voice overnight said that this
sort of
uh behavior is entirely unacceptable uh
and
there are you know many uh many sanction
uh tools uh
and other tools available to the
international community to make
uh that clear and i have no doubt the
forensic she will uh
speak further to us today yes but i mean
we've got a huge problem here haven't we
i mean when there were big
protests and riots last year there were
asset
freezes there were travel sanctions and
so
some of those asset freezes on on
president lukashenka and members of his
family
none of that seems to have had any
impact
whatsoever people on the ground telling
us the situation has got worse rather
than better
so as i've said the foreign secretary
will no doubt uh make more case but he
was very clear last night as has
all the international community been
that uh
this is not acceptable and the
international community
will make its views very clearly heard
um can i ask you about travel to spain
spain saying it's going to welcome us
all
back in now with as long as we have a
negative test before we go
then we can go to spain but it's on our
amber list
what should we do so the prime
minister's been clear that for now
amber means uh please don't go unless
there is a
you know an urgent family reason and so
on because we are still
trying to slowly move uh through our
roadmap
uh to being able to open up on the 21st
of june
and we want to do that in a steady and
careful way which is why we've created
the traffic light system
uh which we obviously hope uh if the
various
constituent parts of what makes a
country uh safe you know
safe to travel to uh moves to green in
due course but amber at the moment still
means
please don't go unless you really need
to and you will of course have to
quarantine
at home for 10 days when you get back
yeah but i mean
the amber the traffic traffic light
system seems to be a bit null and void
now doesn't it i mean the audit seems to
be
green you can go anything else you can't
so we are having to move slowly and
carefully and we want to
away from the we can't do anything
because we are now
vaccinating in such an impressive way
across the uk
that we want to be able to get to a
point where we don't have to have those
limits but we want to move in a steady
way
make sure we are managing and
understanding uh the risks both
uh to our citizens and the risk they
might bring back from other countries
uh which is why we're doing this in a
methodical way so we have now got the
traffic light system
and there are a few countries now green
and we hope very much uh that
obviously the amber numbers will become
more green and due course but the prime
minister being very clear
at the moment today that means uh amber
countries really aren't
uh safe to go to and if you do go you
will
forgive me for jumping in forgive me but
what is the problem with spain
at the moment then what is the specific
problem with spain that that is meaning
we can't go there does even i don't have
the details you need to speak to the
health secretary to get the details of
exactly what the specifics are but it's
numbers of
numbers of cases in hospitals it's the
uh genomic sequencing
of the variants those are the pieces of
information that
our jcbi is using to assess
the state of readiness for a country to
become a green country for our citizens
um can i ask you about the covid scheme
this pilot scheme that's being rolled
out it's allowing some people to get
extra funding to um i mean if they live
in a crowded accommodation to be put
somewhere else if
if they're self-isolating i mean apart
from the fact this doesn't actually give
them any more money in their pocket
which would be a
an incentive to decide to self-isolate
in a
in a better way the problem with this is
we're coming to the end of all this
aren't we this seems to be brought in
12 13 14 months too late
so this is about again where we've seen
these um
sudden increases again from the variant
which uh has originated in india
that we want to be able to help give
people the tools absolutely as many
tools as possible to help them be able
to do the right thing
and selfishly we know that
self-isolation as a system is incredibly
effective that's why
we locked down and we asked everyone to
stay at home so this is again another
tool
as we try and make sure that we don't
see a rise
in this new variant spreading through
because it does seem to be more
transmissible it's an opportunity
another tool to help people do the right
thing and
uh put themselves uh out of out of
transmissibility for ten days so it's
i mean forgive me but i mean the labour
party's been saying for
well the best part of a year now that
you know you need to be giving
anyone who needs to self-isolate needs
to be given more financial support
to encourage them to stay at home to
make sure they're not heading out to
work
so there has been all the way through
for those who for whom
um self icing was financial challenge
there was a 500 pound payment
uh and these have also all been part of
the tools those of us who were employed
and were able to stay at home
uh you know if we were uh needing to
self isolate have been supported uh by
our employers but there has
have been that 500 payments and this is
as we are starting to
unravel the lockdown which is fantastic
news and that's thanks to our amazing
amazing vaccination program uh we want
to make sure
that people who do still test positive
are able to
uh stay out of the way and keep
themselves
uh quarantined for 10 days to try and
break those chains of transmission
now i know there's there's a push today
over green technologies and getting
more sort of green investment in the uk
you're talking about 166 million pounds
of investment and 60
000 new jobs which all sounds great but
where does this fall within
the the 250 000 jobs already announced
and the billion pounds of investment
so this is part of the billion pounds of
investment this is as we start to
uh really work out how we're going to
invest and how we're going to help
industry to find those solutions uh
what uh we're doing is setting out a
number of new funds so that
in terms of hydrogen supply carbon
capture and storage
uh removal of greenhouse gases a whole
series
of technological innovation areas these
are now the funds being allocated to
help businesses
to really uh crack on with finding those
solutions
for their high intensity industries so
but it's not announcing any actual new
money then
so it's how it's starting to actually
deliver uh on what in the
in the energy white paper and the ten
point plan at the end of last year
we set out that big picture uh direction
of travel now we're really starting to
get into the
into the gritty detail of helping those
high energy industries
to decarbonize because we want those
industries to be incredibly successful
but they need to
use clean energy so this is helping them
to
deliver for their sectors uh the sorts
of innovations that are gonna
help them do that so these are a whole
series of
new programs to help them work that out
this is a
team effort decarbonizing our our syst
our energy systems is a completely team
effort for the whole
nation and these innovations that these
businesses come up with will also be
those that we can
help the rest of the world to help
decarbonize too so it's a very exciting
step forwards on our journey to net zero
okay minister good to talk to you this
morning thank you
lovely thank you bye well this is sky
news breakfast let's see what the
weather's going to do for you today and
you know what it might is it
is it toss a coin there's to see what
because it was
torrential rain and then beautiful
sunshine yesterday where i was
yeah and there's more of the same for
today and in fact for tomorrow as well
but once we get the next couple of days
out the way from around wednesday
onwards
pressure is going to become higher
therefore it will become drier
brighter and warmer for most places
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning get well some good news on
the horizon from the middle of this week
onwards we're generally going to see
pressure
becoming higher therefore it will become
drier brighter
and warmer although don't get too
excited by warmer what i mean is that it
won't feel as cool as it has been
but actually temperatures will be around
average for most places for the time of
year
until then they're well below average
for today it's a chilly start this
morning
many places starting off dry with lots
of sunshine but there are some showers
scattered across parts of ireland wales
northwest and southwest england
towards some central and southern
england as well and also some more
persistent rain across northern and east
and parts of scotland
that rain will be sinking its way a
little further southwards across
scotland to the central belt
than southern scotland and northern
ireland by the end of today elsewhere
widespread showers with a risk of hail
and thunderstorms throughout the day
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nas thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast how should the west deal with
president lukashenko of belarus
after he forced a flight carrying an
opposition journalist to land as it flew
over his country
in december i was on a
video call with a colleague and
unfortunately
found like a rash going up my chest
which i think was due to the medication
i was taking
i rang my dermatologist who told me
swollen lymph nodes can happen on his
medication
wait three weeks see what happens
obviously the lump never went
there was in that time i did the usual
of googling my symptoms
no mention of thyroid cancer and then
eventually um i went and had various
scans
and a biopsy and found out i had
papillary thyroid cancer when i found
out
luckily it was on the phone so i could
be with my husband or i would have found
out on
on my own um due to covert um
but i was deeply upset scared
i have three children um you think the
worst
but my surgeon was really reassuring
thyroid had
a higher cure rate if cat caught early
um and i was just hoping that it hadn't
spread
anywhere else i had my thyroid
completely removed
um i'm now on thyroxine i will be on
that for the rest of my life
and eventually i will have radioactive
iodine therapy
which will hopefully kill all the
remaining cancer cells
i'm under amazing care with adam brooks
and they have been fantastic so i feel
like i'm in the best hands
um but to be honest doing this campaign
is what's driving me and keeping me
positive
the thought that i could help someone my
age realize that
how important it is to check your neck
and so that is definitely helping and i
feel like this happened to me for a
reason
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
international leaders have strongly
condemned the arrest of a belarusian
dissident journalist after the ryanair
flight he was travelling on
was forced to land in the belarusian
capital minsk
a short time ago i spoke to the business
minister anne-marie trevely who said the
actions of belarus were
concerning as the foreign secretary
uh said last night uh and uh no doubt
uh there will be statements this week in
the house this is
unacceptable and we are very uh
concerned by that behavior
uh and i think all parties uh have been
very clear that this is a
breach of uh normal
uh international laws and i have no
doubt the foreign sector will make
more uh clarity on his message from last
night let's head to bratislava and we
can talk to the director of the think
tank globsec
elena cutsco good to see you this
morning are you surprised that president
lukashenka has
been so brazen in his actions
even by the centers of the current
belarusian regime
this is a totally new level of
escalation and the totally
new level of risk that the government is
willing to take
what does it tell us about the attitude
of president lukashenko towards
the west in particular lukashenko
is sending a very clear message he cares
very little about the international
community
specifically the western countries and
he cares very little about the
international
norms and rules for him his domestic
survival is much more important
currently
he knows that despite everything that is
shown on the state television
he is still very vulnerable and the only
way for him to remain in power
is to go after his opponents in any way
he can
that's why he is very emboldened in
international action
but also he has this feeling of impunity
over the past year he was able to get
away with quite a lot
the sanctions that were imposed on him
are rather
not that painful for him and this is the
risk that he is willing to take
because the costs for him are still
significantly lower than the benefits
what is the situation in belarus at the
moment because we saw the
large protest yesterday last year in the
run-up to the election
but since then from an outsider's
perspective it seems to have quietened
down
quite a lot now has the anger dissipated
or is it simply that he has managed to
stamp down on the protests
this feeling of quiet is exactly the
image that lukashenko is trying to
portray
but it is this is rather an illusion the
only way that he has managed to do so is
very brutal treatment of people who are
trying to protest
or who are trying to demonstrate their
descent in any way
this incident with the airplane should
not be treated as a random incident
that is isolated that the broader
developments in the country
over the past months the regime has been
tightening the screw
on the opposition and protesters dozens
of people are being arrested on a daily
basis for
charges that range from forwarding a
message from a
telegram channel that has been banned by
the government to wearing
white red white socks for examples the
conditions in prisons are very brutal
there are a lot of reports of torture
a political prisoner died last week but
also it is important to remember
that lukashenka is trying to crack down
on the information
space last week a major news portal
portal
to dubai has been effectively shut down
by the government
with most of the senior editorial team
is currently being in detention awaiting
trial
so the government does try to crack down
brutally but also control the
information space
well i mean what do you think the
international community
can do there's been outrage from the the
british government the irish government
the united states
but if you say that you know that the
sanctions last year the
travel sanctions and the asset freezing
hasn't really stopped
lukashenko what more can be done
sanctions that have been imposed over
the past year are rather limited
they only concern a couple dozens
individuals
but also only a few companies so it's
not very painful so the sanctions to
have effect
need to be much more painful it is also
important for international community to
indicate that what is
happening right now and what happened
yesterday is unacceptable
this might be very contagious as other
authoritarian governments might have
similar
ideas but also the current case is not
only about the development in the
country
it directly affects the safety of the
european citizens who were effectively
kidnapped for several
hours by an authoritarian government
what can be done is definitely
much broader set of economic sanctions
imposed on the
state-owned companies but also with
people on people who are
known to help lukashenka perpetrate the
crimes domestically
and it's important to do it in
solidarity between the european union
the united kingdom but also the united
states
there are a lot of discussions whether
for example the flights
and air traffic between belarus and the
european union should be
stopped entirely i'm not a proponent of
this measure
simply because it also makes it much
more difficult for people for dissidents
to leave the country and potentially put
more people in
in in terms of dissidence and we know
roman er protesovic was
was not living in the country he'd moved
out but
how there are lots of reports about what
his
his future may hold now how difficult is
it going
to be for anyone to keep a track of what
is happening
to him now it will be very difficult we
have
no information currently whatsoever
about what is going on in his case where
he is and what is happening to him
the communication with the people who
are currently in prison for their
political activity is very scarce
that typically only allowed to
communicate through
their lawyers on an ad hoc basis or
through
occasional letters but there is
definitely
not much information about what's going
on there
say nothing about what's going to happen
to them
in the future in the past the regime was
ready to
bargain with the west for the release of
political prisoners
but in the current situation it seems
like the regime is not ready even for
this discussion
so unfortunately the fortunes of these
people
are very dark currently okay elena
cutsco good to talk to you this morning
thank you
thank you for having me now a senior
hamas leader has told sky news the
group's
current ceasefire should hold but warned
there was currently no
chance of making peace with israel in
his first interview since the
ceasefire mahmoud zahar hamas co-founder
denied that the group fires rockets from
civilian areas and said he would be
willing to talk to the u.s president
joe biden while he was talking to our
correspondent mark stone
who's in gaza hello
assalamu alaikum how are you mahmud zaha
is back at his gaza home after two weeks
lying low
as a founding member of hamas he is for
israel
a target first of all can you tell us
the status of the ceasefire we're we're
a few days into it it seems to be
holding
yes i think most of the important point
is the degree of
impact on both sides i think
nobody in both sides is looking
for escalation more than what happened
before
so i i believe that it will continue
eleven days of conflict between israel
and hamas left 260 dead
most in gaza yet dr zaha claims hamas
achieved a strategic
and symbolic victory the new element
here
is the degree of the resistant movement
in
particular in gaza to attack the israeli
targets
and very important points including most
of the overcrowded
area in this in the civilian
interference society
so for how long the israeli will accept
that
i think this is the main issue you are
firing
missiles rockets and missiles from
civilian areas
here in gaza at civilians
in israel that that's not acceptable is
it that's a war crisis no single rockets
were sent from for from the from a
civilian area we
most of the the rockets from the border
that's not true though is it because we
this is a troop
we've seen video of rockets being fired
from within
the the built-up area of gaza city at
israeli communities
this is not against the israeli
committee this is against israeli
occupation
israeli aggression are you not at least
in part responsible for the conditions
here because you hamas
spend your money on weapons you spend
your money on tunnels
you spend your money on fighters you are
not spending your money
on the civilian population here give me
one example in the world
that they have no military ministry
to defend himself we are here
protecting ourselves against aggression
against the israeli aggression
does the state of israel have the right
to exist
no why why
you are coming from america and you take
my house you came from britain and you
took my
brother house you took this is a
settlement
this is a settlement not you are not a
citizen
we are the owner of this is this is area
arabic area will known
this is well known as islamic area well
known so you are
you are telling me now that you you
don't think the two-state solution is
possible
practically practically that was
proved it is not my assessment if
president biden was willing to sit down
with you
with hamas would you talk to him why not
why
not why not mr biden
yes he is supporting israel but i think
we have we have we have a mission as a
palestinian people
to speak to him frankly it will come as
a relief
for many that senior hamas officials
believe this ceasefire will hold
for now but like so much in this
conflict the gulf between the two sides
remains vast let me ask you one last
thing
how would you define peace peace mean
justice
no peace without justice
and the prospects for long-term peace as
elusive as ever
mark stone sky news in gaza
well still to come on sky news breakfast
could a team of
dogs train to sniff out covid19
help stop the virus
[Music]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do
they fear they'll be killed
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
day
can't access those and knees
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us there are
people
wading through it
[Music]
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment i don't like the
chinese government it's true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber bullets
see fires all around us here and just
one of them
is the size of around 31 000 football
pitches
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok
[Music]
for the early rises
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast for wherever you
are welcome to
safety rage watch for the ones who want
to know more welcome to the all-out
politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know symptoms of hay
fever can develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
there will be widespread showers
developing over most of ireland
england and wales this afternoon some of
them heavy and thundery with hail
meanwhile northern and eastern scotland
will have spells of rain with heavy
downpours slowly spreading southwards
to central scotland and northern ireland
later it'll be a breezy day too
especially across coastal parts of the
north and south and temperatures
will be well below average for the time
of year
pollen levels will remain low for all
areas today mainly due to the unsettled
conditions
currently small amounts of grass pollen
are now airborne
oak tree pollen poses a risk during
spells of sunny dry weather as well and
spores will increase temporarily after
any rain
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
now a team of bio-detection dogs have
been trained to smell if someone is
infected with covid19 a study found the
canines are able to detect the virus in
people who are showing
no symptoms well i love this sort of
story let's talk to claire guest from
the medical detection dog she's the ceo
and james logan who's
from the london school of hygiene and
tropical medicine good to see you all
this morning good to see your pooches
as well claire i know you've got a
couple there look i mean how
how effective are dogs noses claire and
actually detecting any sort of medical
condition
well they're incredibly effective and
although ash is doing a very good
example here but dog has been woken up
too early
um they have 350 million sensor
receptors dedicated to olfaction now
this means they can spell
a teaspoon of sugar in the equivalent of
um two olympic sized swimming pools us
humans can smell it
in a cup of tea so we're talking about a
very
very reliable and accurate biosensor
and these dogs absolutely love to work
and medical protection dogs we've been
working for the last
10 years indicate finding that dogs can
indeed
detect the odor of human disease and
this is said for
our coverage 19 detective work now okay
james i mean how confident are you in
all of this now you've been involved in
looking at the data
oh to run the study at the london school
finding chocolate medicine with
uh medical detection dogs and um yeah i
mean
you know what what we found was that the
dogs could
detect correctly if somebody was
infected with covet
94 of the time and what's really
incredible about these dogs
is that they can do it really really
quickly so each individual dog could
screen up to 250 to 300 people per
hour what we also find was that the dogs
were able to detect people who didn't
have any symptoms
and also people with a low viral load so
those could be people who are at the
beginning of their infection and
not really detectable because they don't
have any symptoms so these results are
really really exciting but
you know they we are sort of early stage
so this is still proof of concept and
the next stage is to get out into the
field and test the dogs in
real world conditions with real people
to see just how well they can do it but
certainly a really exciting first step
okay so claire getting getting the dogs
out about in the real world how easy is
that to do because i mean how
how many do you have trained up
well in the first studies james said we
have we had six dogs that showed the
proof of concept
we've got another 10 dogs that are
actually have been trained to detect
this virus um on
on people so wearing clothing currently
that's been collected the dogs have
indicated that they
are are able to do just as well on on on
people as they move
around the environment and of course
scale up is a challenge but you know
dogs can detect two dogs could detect um
could screen 300 um individuals in half
an hour as they got also an aircraft
so we're talking about a very very rapid
test
and this is something that could really
change the way in which
diagnostics look because you could do a
rapid screen and then follow it up with
a pcr
test and this can make a huge difference
how quickly do they get nose blind
um we work dogs for about 20 minutes at
a time
and um this means that they're at
absolute peak performance
and then they'd hand over to an another
doggy team and once they had a rest so
um they they're perfectly capable of
working for at least 20 minutes without
without any problems at
all yeah i mean in all of this james
it's all about looking at the
it's incredible but you have to look at
the practical applications of this and
as claire said actually
getting if you had a team of dogs that
could get on every plane
and just see if there's anyone on a
plane i mean that that actually could
have
huge real world implications couldn't it
yes absolutely so you know what what we
have to be very clear about is we're not
saying that dogs could replace pcr
or lateral flow testing or anything like
that and you would need too many dogs to
be able to do that
um but as claire said you know we could
screen
a plane for the people in half an hour
with two dogs and
what we could look at is is whether we
can target
uh this method so you know we might go
to screen certain flights that are
coming into the uk
for example but not just flights um you
know we in our paper that we we've we've
just released today
um you know we did look at airports as
one
scenario of where we could use dogs but
dogs could be used in a number of
different scenarios including
uh sporting events and stadiums uh train
stations
maybe even workplaces as well so um the
the the real key to this is the speed
there is nothing else that compares to
that sort of speed
um of screening people very very rapidly
so there could be lots of opportunities
if we can have enough dogs to to use in
the field in the real world
i mean why do you think claire we've
been sort of slow on the uptake on this
that
i don't just mean with with the coverage
situation but i know there are
are hypo hounds for type 1 diabetics
going hypo who who don't have symptoms
of that
there are cancer sniffing dogs there are
i mean
it's all these amazing things that dogs
can do and although we've known about it
it's never really taken off
well i mean that's a very good point and
you know at the charity
we've been working for over 10 years now
to get an evidence base
to actually show that although these
biosensors
have got a fluffy coat and wacky tail
and then face
a very fluffy top knot you know he is a
very very
accurate biosensor and i think the
skepticism
is that you know well how could a dog
possibly do this but of course we use
these dogs to keep us safe
in terms of finding drugs explosives and
you know they are relied upon to keep us
safe and this is just another
application of the dog's incredible
sense of smell
and his willingness to to look for odor
and you know the skepticism is slowing
things down you know we need to get
these dogs
out there as soon as we can to assist in
this this fight against um
19 just like they they assisted in the
fight against um
terrorism explosions so you know this is
a very very serious
um serious science behind all our work
yeah look i don't want to take anything
away from the dogs james
in any but it is there a way that we can
access the you know their sort of
natural skill set their
their natural physical abilities can we
adapt that into technology at some point
yeah i mean this is something else that
we're looking at as as well is
uh you know how can we could we develop
sensors that could do the job of a dog's
nose
and the reality is that um i i
personally think that dogs are more
capable than any machine
that uh that currently exists from what
i've seen in all honesty
um however we are doing some work um on
sensors and and i think that
um you know that could potentially be an
another way forward
um in the future as well i think dogs
will have
um a role to play um for some time and
as i said the key is that they're so so
rapid
and the sensor work the technology is a
little bit further behind in terms of
the development so dogs are what we
could get out very very quickly
okay look really good to talk to you
james and to you claire and to your two
little furry friends there
and we don't see we've not seen much of
the lab but i know he's lurking there in
the corner
sorry they've not been very dynamic it's
a bit early in the morning
who can blame him who can blame look
really good to see you all thank you